it can seem illogical that Kevin never
calls the police until the end of the
movie choosing instead to construct an
elaborate series of booby traps to
protect himself but by Kevin's logic it
actually makes sense he thinks he made
his family Disappear by Magic and when
he later encounters the wet Bandits he
recognizes Harry as the police officer
who visited his house earlier police
can't help with a magically disappearing
family and they may in fact be the bad
guys if Harry is one of them but it's
less clear why the pizza guy doesn't
call 911 after he delivers a pie to the
mallister home and Kevin uses the angels
with filthy souls video to trick him
into believing someone is trying to kill
him the ruse clearly works but then
nothing happens if he's under the
impression that one of his customers
just tried to kill him he' think he'd
call the police or at least report it to
his manager who could pass the incident
along to the authorities but it appears
that instead he just keeps it to himself
and goes about the rest of his day